Rumer Willis knows what it takes to take
home that Mirrorball trophy
the former Dancing with the Stars champ
has some advice for this season's cast
they're doing something in a very
accelerating pace and when you're in a
concept of time isn't really there and
it's just really take a moment enjoy it
enjoy the experience enjoy learning and
the challenges and all of it you've got
really close with the cast right and the
big answer that of it you know Cheryl
Burke recently just actually slammed her
celebrity partner is it as tense as it
seems between partners cuz I mean you
spend a lot of time together and
rehearsing yeah I mean to be honest you
know I I don't know if I was just
luckier but I think that you know you
really have to come in with a headspace
of of what you're wanting if you come in
with a good attitude and we're ready to
you know work and participate and make
it the best situation possible for
everybody included then I think you
can't really fail
the 27 year old currently stars as Anne
Hathaway's character in the unauthorized
musical parody of The Devil Wears Prada
in LA and experience she likens to her
time on dancing oh for sure I mean I
think just being challenged every week
to try something new and and not just
challenge your body of a challenge I
might as well I mean that's why I kind
of love doing new things and even coming
back and doing the show like this I love
being around people who are talented
because that makes me want to kind of
step up my own game you know would you
ever do like an all-star round of the
show oh for sure yeah I will be a judge
yeah I would love that I mean I think
it's it's such a cool world and I've
always been a huge fan of dance but you
know be able to do that again it'll be
amazing